what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and I'm back at it again to
discuss the latest crazy chapter of one
piece and wow we got so much to talk
about including the shocking conclusion
of the Luffy vs awakened Lucci fight the
secret behind the seraphims and their
powers an insane reveal about devil
fruits and the appearance of an admiral
and more so make sure to stay tuned for
this action-packed insane chapter
Channel parking with it and smash that
like button if you enjoy seeing these
one piece reviews and want to keep them
coming be a smashing Power King rather
passing Orochi and the universe will
reward you make this the video you
joined the nakama if you haven't already
by hitting that subscribe button and
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one piece reviews and updates and I know
some of you don't even know that you're
not subscribed so just take a look below
the video and make sure you are
subscribed it only takes a few seconds
and now without further Ado let's jump
into its spoilers and all so this
chapter is called the most powerful
beings in the world and if that's not a
hype title chapter I don't know what is
now we start the chapter with santomaru
being stricken down in gear 5 Luffy
understandably worrying eyes popping out
and everything he apologizes saying he
he didn't mean to distract santomaru
while the latter says he did see the
attack coming and thought he blocked it
but the implication is that's just how
tough awaken Luchi is even if you block
it it still almost ends you and based on
the title we could infer that along with
Luffy Luchi is now one of the strongest
beings in the world so this does make
sense however the title can also apply
to something else as we'll see but more
on that later luch even compliments that
the waters saying he's tough but he
needs him out of the picture since as we
saw a last chapter sotomaru outranks
them in command hierarchy when it comes
to seraphims and everyone wants to
ridiculously overpowered seraphims on
their side and I don't blame them
especially after what we're gonna learn
in this chapter luckily Luffy steps in
and uses booming white whip to send
Luchi flying he spins so much himself
that he can't stop spending even after
the move is finished you gotta love the
complete lack of seriousness that Luffy
brings into serious fights in this form
I wonder if it'll be a significant
weakness when he comes up against
Blackbeard or some other top tier
opponent down the line since Luffy seems
to prioritize having fun as much as
winning Jim has to tell Luffy to hurry
and they gotta get the vegapunk fast to
save Atlas hilariously though Luffy
doesn't stop spinning and the spinning
even starts causing him to move in the
opposite direction we then see some
seraphims going off the little mihawk
with his sword and Little Jim Bay with
his swim swim fruit powers and once
again what perfect powers for a Fishman
amazing imagine being able to use all of
those insane swimming powers on land so
op the seraphims are built up even more
when Kaku mentions that they are
unstoppable and then it's mentioned that
it's even more terrifying when you
remember that they're still just
children of course the crazy implication
there is they'll continue to grow and
get stronger as time goes on I gotta
admit I wasn't crazy about the seraphims
because I don't like the idea of
scientific Creations like pacifista
surpassing humans in power but clearly
Oda is making it clear that they are
extremely powerful and have the
potential to become even more powerful
they aren't just decorative or fodder
they can easily turn the tides of a
fight let me know in the comments if
you're cool with that or if it also kind
of rubs you the wrong way having Korea
Creations being so overpowered
especially compared to humans Frankie
Goes On To Cry recognizing that little
jinbei is using the swimsuit that
belongs to his sworn brother Senor pink
he's worried that since only one person
can have a fruit at a time it could mean
pink has bit the dust but Frankie is
told that he's currently an inmate at
impel down and then when Frankie asks if
they made a copy of his fruit we get
some insanely interesting information
about devil fruits and how far Vega Punk
has come to being able to replicate
their powers so it's said that so far it
has only been possible to manufacture
Zone fruits artificially as we saw with
Momo and his kaido copy fruit I also
love how vegapunk mentioned Caesar's
smile fruit method only to disregard it
quickly as being unacceptable vegapunk
explains that he's fairly certain with
unlimited resources even special types
of devil fruits can be recreated but and
this is very interesting he still hasn't
confirmed if such synthesized fruits can
be awakened fascinating stuff here
science has really gotten to a crazy
level here and it could get even crazier
according to vegapunk logus and
Awakening things seem to be the most
Troublesome to recreate along with the
fact that artificial fruit Awakenings
never happened yet Vega Punk hasn't been
able to get low yes right either saying
they are trickier than he expected so
even though devil fruits may seem less
special now that they can be reproduced
like this at least so far logius and
awakened fruits have kept their Prestige
which I really like one of the first
questions that pops up would be can he
recreate another Luffy but since gear 5
Luffy is awakened it's more likely that
he could just give someone rubber Powers
by creating an artificial sun god fruit
which is nowhere near as impressive as
where Luffy is today vegapunk then says
something else that's fascinating to me
they did come up with an alternative for
copying paramecia Powers he says you can
synthesize a blood additive from a
paramecia user's lineage factor that
will grant their power once transfused
vegapunk calls it green blood and you
can visibly see it running through the
arms of the seraphims Frankie is shocked
that he could actually create blood and
this is when one of our big questions
are answered can the Clones of the
Warlords use their devil fruits and we
see boa used the power of the love love
Fruita turn characters into stone just
like boa is able to do Vega punk goes on
to Hype up the seraphims by saying
they're the culmination of his ideas aka
the culmination of his genius we see
Kuma similarly using fruit Powers when
he uses ursa's shock next Mega punk
calls the seraphims the peak of what our
signs can accomplish and even adds that
they may very well go down as the most
powerful beings in the history of the
sea this is a crazy statement since of
course the yonko and Admirals are also
competing for that title of the most
powerful being and here the title of the
chapter takes on another possible
meaning as mentioned referring to the
seraphims rather than to Luchi or even
to Luffy it's a crazy statement for sure
and these guys who I never thought would
be a threat for the ankles or for
Admirals are being hyped up as if they
could be Sanji remarks that they are
basically Navy weapons and Robin says
yes and they pose a huge threat to us
meaning to the straw hats it's crazy
because Blackbeard wanted to prevent the
Navy from getting bullets insane devil
through Power and yet they still have it
through the seraphim these seraphims
aren't just strong and they are really
strong their abilities make them very
tricky too as awakened Luchi moves in to
finish off sento Maru Luffy steps in and
while must be one of my favorite panels
in the chapter he grows his head and
prepares to swallow up Luchi although
props to Luchi he reacts quick enough to
avoid it yeah Luffy is having a bunch of
fun but you gotta give props to Luchi
for surviving so long against the yonko
who beat kaido himself I love seeing
Luffy use one of the surrounding tubes
and rubberizing slash tunifying it so
that propels him like a slingshot he
even puts on goggles and Bam lands an
insane hit on Luchi that stretches him
more than any being should ever be able
to stretch luch even remarks what insane
power Luffy just laughs uncontrollably
as Luchi is sent flying we see two think
bubbles saying I'm losing Consciousness
can't hold on which I assume is a
continuation of luchi's thoughts and
it's likely about his awakened form in
the meantime little boa helps our guys
by pointing them to the vacuum rocket
Jim thanks for saying it's nice to see a
kind version of boa which is hilarious
they created a little boy with the
personality of a tsundere and so she
calls him an insulin dummy and says that
she's just following orders it's
interesting that they actually have
personalities like this and aren't just
killing machines devoid of emotion our
guys tell Luffy to hurry Santo Maru
tells Luffy that he's trusting vagapan
to him and Luffy promises to get him off
this island no matter what in the end
Luffy after dominating the fight makes
it to the rocket in time notably Luffy
is in a clearly exhausted and Droopy
form after using gear 5 to Bonnie's
shock we're told the ride should take 32
seconds on the super fast rocket they
arrive and we're told all other flights
have been canceled so now it should be
really hard for cp0 to get to them so it
looks good for our guys except for one
detail which we'll get into later but
let me know if you can guess in the
comments after we're shown barricades
and security being improved we jump to
CP 0 and they seem to complement Luffy
saying you have to hand it to him
vegapunk couldn't ask for a better
bodyguard we see Luchia notably he
doesn't have a droopy form or exhausted
form like Luffy he looks fine despite
also using his Awakening for an extended
period of time their orders are to wait
for the Marines but Luchi worries that
if they wait too long the straw hats
will get away back to vegapunk and the
others they are surprised that the
government wants to kill the smartest
man in the world although it's not
surprising to vegapunk it's said that
nobody wants that level of intellect to
turn against them and now that they have
the seraphims the Pinnacle of the
science they want to make sure he can't
help anyone else plus if they kill
vegapunk the seraphims will obey the
world government officials without issue
it makes sense from a Machiavellian
point of view why the government doesn't
want vegapunk to stay alive Mega punk
calls the fact that ayanko's crew like
the straw has showed up just as things
came to a head was a serendipitous twist
of fate as the crew welcomes vegapunka
board Bonnie says she's going to kill
him if he doesn't return her father back
to normal we also see cp0 and the power
of the seraphims behind them they are
committed to not letting any vegapunks
survive and this is now definitely a
hard challenge for the straw hats with
the very much hyped up seraphims against
them and oh my God I just thought of
Zorro taking on many Hawkeye I know I
should have thought of that before but I
just thought of it now and that would be
crazy it would be a crazy stepping stone
before beating mihawk himself but Oda
May prioritize Escape here rather than a
definitive defeat especially because as
we see the one and only kizero appears
and he's bringing help he says that on
paper for the straw hats it's a
straightforward Escape but that the
straw hats are in for a surprise not
only will kisaru Aid cp0 and the
seraphims they will also get as many
warships as possible to Egghead we're
told the might of the Navy draws near
and wow this is getting insane good job
Oda for setting up an actually
challenging situation soon after Luffy
beat kaido and unlocked a ridiculous New
Gear let me know your thoughts on this
chapter and what you expect to happen
next will there be a big definitive
fight will we finally see kisado go down
or will something happen and allow the
straw hats to escape without a real
fight perhaps another 4 course joints it
helps the straw hats Escape perhaps
Blackbeard even joins the party
eventually and if you're curious about
what that could mean for the Marines or
the straw hats right now don't miss this
new video about Blackbeard's insanely op
crew and their insane new powers link on
screen and in the description